I think there was tongue well that just
happened and it was this beautiful
moment Howard Stern visited The Ellen
DeGeneres Show on Monday hilariously at
snagging this passionate kiss with his
longtime pal
daytime television and me perfect
pairing here's how it all went down the
61 year old comedian and Stern talked
about recent backlash she received for
sitting next to former president george
w bush at an NFL game and in an effort
to help distract from it all he offered
this hilarious service what you need to
do in my opinion let's take the picture
with me making out with me and I will
say what's on my mind
DeGeneres quickly pointed out that
Stern's wife Beth was in attendance your
wife is here I know I know but that
didn't stop the funny moment from
happening you're so smart to do this
here we go
hold it
I think there was tongue later in the
episode Ellen brought out the bachelors
Colton Underwood who got ordained so he
could help Howard and Beth renew their
wedding vows let's just say set them
right off the bat Colton's got to get a
job you remarry me I promise for the
rest of my life to watch The Bachelor
with you in bed every single night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]